5 14 on your Finally Friday what's cool
is cool well as amazing as the Clark
County School District's food service
department is they probably didn't mind
when a local elementary school had a
special treat for breakfast last week
first though a shout out to those men
and women of the CCSD Food Service
preparing and serving tens of thousands
of free nutritious meals every day
including some of the best homemade
cinnamon rolls you'll ever have from
their enormous kitchen and Warehouse in
the Northeast Valley
now to that special breakfast last
Thursday at Elaine Wind Elementary where
every kid who wanted one got one of
those super cool fancy Chef hats the
chefs for kids program was sponsored by
MGM Grand whose chefs whipped up
Specialties like chicken and sweet cream
Belgian waffle skewers rocket rice
pudding with French vanilla blueberry
and strawberry this young person made
quick work out of that chicken and
waffle deal while enjoying a gluten-free
muffin and a Jamba Juice Smoothie
yeah baby chicken and waffle skewers so
the chefs for kids meal also had some
help from volunteers from the Las Vegas
American culinary Federation they'll be
visiting a dozen other Title One schools
throughout the year we always want to
know what's cool at school if you got
something let us know cool at school
under the Community tab at 8newsnow.com
or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com I'm just the the rocket
rice pudding with blueberry and
strawberry and a gluten-free muffin come
on I mean will you see mystery meat
exactly and maybe a little thing of milk
yeah yeah I've never thought of the idea
of putting chicken and waffles on a
skewer it's a great idea it really
bite-sized pieces yeah and you don't
have to sit there and struggle with the
chicken and the kids had no problem with
that yeah